The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Welcome back to 6046.
Today we continue our
theme of data structures
but this time, instead of doing
a fancy cool data structure,
we're going to look
at fancy cool analysis
techniques for data structures.
And these are useful for tons
of different data structures,
especially in the context when
you're using a data structure
to implement an algorithm.
For example, in Dijkstra, when
you learn Dijkstra's algorithm,
you had lots of
different heap structures
you could use for the
priority queue in Dijkstra,
and they gave different
running times with Dijkstra.
But the key thing
in that context
is that you cared about
the total running time
of the algorithm,
less than you cared
about the individual running
time of each operation.
That's what
amortization is about.
It's, I guess, a technique
from financial analysis,
but we've appropriated
it in computer science
as an analysis technique
to say, well, let's not
worry about every single
operation worst case cost,
let's just worry about the
total operation, the sum
of all the operations cost.
That's the whole
idea of amortization,
but there's a lot of
different ways to do it.
We're going to cover four
different methods for doing it,
and three-ish examples
of doing it today.
You've seen some essentially
in recitation last time,
and you've seen a
little bit in 6006,
so let me first remind you of
the example of table doubling
from 6006.
This came up in the
context of hash tables.
As you may recall,
if you store n items
in a hash table of size m--
there are m slots in the table,
let's say, using chaining--
hashing with chaining-- then we
got an expected
cost constant plus
the load factor, size
of the table divided
by the number of items.
So we wanted to get
constant expected,
and so we wanted this to
always be, at most, a constant.
I guess we could handle
a larger table size,
although then we are
unhappy about our space,
but we definitely want m to be
at least around n so that this
works out to order one.
And the solution for doing
that was table doubling.
Whenever the table is
too big, double it--
or sorry-- whenever
the table is too small
and we have too many items,
double the size of the table.
If n-- n is the thing
that we can't control.
That's the number
of items somebody
is inserting into the table.
If n grows to the value
to match m, then double m.
So m prime equals 2m, and
to double the table size,
you have to allocate a new
array of double the size
and copy over all the items,
and that involves hashing.
But overall this will take
order, size of the table, work.
Doesn't matter whether I'm
using m or m prime here,
because they're within a
constant factor of each other,
and that's bad.
Linear time to do an
insertion is clearly bad.
This is all during one
insertion operation
that this would happen,
but overall it's
not going to be bad, because
you only double log n times.
And if you look at
the total cost--
so maybe you think, oh,
is it log n per operation,
but it's not so bad because
total cost for n insertions
starting from an empty structure
is something like 2 to the 0--
this is a big theta outside--
2 to the 1, 2 to the 2.
If we're only doing
insertions, this is great.
2 to the log n.
This is a geometric series
and so this is order n.
Theta head I guess.
So to do n insertions,
cost theta n,
so we'd like to say the
amortized cost per operation
is constant, because
we did n operations.
Total cost was n, so sort
of on average per operation,
that was the only constant.
So this is the sense in which
hash tables are constant,
expected, amortized.
And we'll get back to
hashing in a future lecture,
probably I think lecture
8, but for now we're
just going to think about
this as a general thing
where you need table doubling,
then this gives you a fast way
to insert into a table.
Later we'll think about
deleting from a table
and keeping the
space not too big,
but that's a starting point.
This is an example of a
general technique called
the aggregate method, which
is probably the weakest
method for doing
amortization but
maybe the most intuitive one.
So the aggregate
method says, well, we
do some sequence of operations.
Let's say, in general,
there are k operations.
Measure the total cost
of those operations,
divide by k, that's the
amortized cost per operation.
You can think of
this as a definition,
but it's not actually
going to be our definition
of amortized cost.
We're going to use a
more flexible definition,
but for simple examples like
this, it's a fine definition,
and it gives you what you want.
When your sequence of
operations is very clear,
like here, there's
only one thing you
can do at each step,
which is insert-- that's
my definition of the
problem-- then great,
we get a very simple sum.
As soon as you mix
inserts and deletes,
the sum is not so clear.
But in some situations,
the sum is really clean,
so you just compute
the sum, divide
by a number of operations,
you get a cost,
and that could be
the amortized cost.
And that's the aggregate method,
works great for simple sums.
Here's another example
where it-- no, sorry.
Let me now give you
the general definition
of amortized bounds,
which becomes important
once you're dealing with
different types of operations.
I want to say an insert
costs one bound amortized
and maybe a delete
costs some other bound.
So what you get to do is assign
a cost for each operation.
I should call it
an amortized cost,
such that you preserve
the sum of those costs.
So what I mean is that if I look
at the sum over all operations
of the amortized cost
of that operation,
and I compare that with the
sum of all the actual costs
of the operations, the
amortize should always
be bigger, because I
always want an upper bound
on my actual cost.
So if I can prove that the
amortized costs are, at most,
say, constant per
operation, then I
get that the sum
of the actual cost
is, at most, constant
per operation.
I don't learn anything
about the individual costs,
but I learn about
the total cost.
And in the context of an
algorithm like Dijkstra's
algorithm, you only care
about the total cost,
because you don't care about
the shortest paths at time t,
you only care about the shortest
paths when the algorithm is
completely finished.
So in a lot of situations,
maybe not a real-time system,
but almost everything
else, you just
care about the sum of the costs.
As long as that's
small, you can afford
the occasional
expensive operation.
So this is a more
flexible definition.
One option would be to
assign the average cost
to each operation, but we have
a whole bunch more operations.
We could say inserts cost
more than deletes or things
like that.
In fact, let me do
such an example.
A couple weeks ago, you
learned about 2-3 trees.
This would work for
any structure though.
So I claim I'm going to look at
three operations on 2-3 trees.
One is create an
empty tree, so I
need to think about
how we're getting
started in amortization.
Let's say you always
start with an empty tree.
It takes constant
time to make one.
I pay log n time-- I'm going
to tweak that a little bit--
for an insertion, and
I pay 0 time per delete
in an amortized sense.
You can write big
O of 0 if you like.
Same thing.
So deletion you can think
of as a free operation.
Why?
This is a bit counter-intuitive
because, of course, in reality
the actual cost of a deletion
is going to be log n.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can never
delete more elements
than you've already inserted.
ERIK DEMAINE: You can
never delete more elements
than you've already inserted.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Can you cap
the cost of [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
So I can bound the deletion
cost by the insertion cost,
and in the context of
just the aggregate method,
you could look at the total
cost of all the operations.
I guess we're not
exactly dividing here,
but if we look at
the total cost,
let's say that we do c
creations, i insertions
and d deletions, then the total
cost becomes c plus i times
log n plus d times the log n.
And the point is d is
less than or equal to i,
because you can never
delete an item that
wasn't already inserted
if you're starting
from an empty structure.
And so this is i plus d
times log n, but that's just,
at most, twice i times log
n, so we get c plus i log n.
And so we can think of that
as having a d times 0, 0
cost per deletion.
So this is the sum of the
actual costs over here.
This is the sum of the
amortized costs, where
we say 0 for the
deletion, and we just
showed that this is an upper
bound on that, so we're happy.
Now, there's a
slight catch here,
and that's why I wrote
star on every n, which
is not every operation
has the same cost, right?
When you start from
an empty structure,
insertion cost constant
time, because n is 0.
When n is a constant,
insertion is constant time.
When n grows to n,
it costs log n time.
At different times, n
is a different value,
and n I'm going to use
to mean the current size
of the structure.
For this argument to
work at the moment,
I need that n is not the
current value, because this
is kind of charging work.
Some insertions are
for large structures,
some are for small structures,
some deletions are for small,
some are for large.
Gets confusing to think about.
We will fix that in a
moment but, for now, I'm
just going to
define n star to be
the maximum size over all time.
OK, if we just define it
that way, then this is true.
That will let me pay
for any deletion,
but we'll remove that
star later on once
we get better analysis
methods, but so far so good.
Two very simple
examples-- table doubling,
2-3 trees with free deletion.
Of course, that would
work for any structure
with logarithmic
insertion and deletion,
but we're going to be using
2-3 trees in a more-- analyzing
them in a more
interesting way later on.
So let's go to the next method,
which is the accounting method.
It's like the bank teller's
analysis, if you will.
These are all just different
ways to compute these sums
or to think about the sums,
and usually one method
is a lot easier, either for you
personally or for each problem,
more typically.
Each problem usually one
or more of these methods
is going to be more
intuitive than the others.
They're all kind of
equivalent, but it's
good to have them
all in your mind
so you can just think about
the problem in different ways.
So with the accounting
method, what we're going to do
is define a bank account and
an operation can store credit
in that bank account.
Credits maybe not the best
word, because you're not
allowed for the bank
account to go negative.
The bank account must always
be non-negative balance,
because otherwise your
summations won't work out.
So when you store credit in the
bank account, you pay for it.
It's as if you're
consuming time now in order
to pay for it in the future.
And think of operations
costing money,
so whenever I do a deletion, I
spend actual time, log n time,
but if I had log n
dollars in the bank,
and I could pull
those out of the bank,
I can use those dollars
to pay for the work,
and then the deletion
itself becomes
free in an amortized sense.
So this is, on the
one hand, operation--
and when I do an insertion,
I'm going to physically take
some coins out of myself.
That will cost
something in the sense
that the amortized
cost of insertion
goes up in order to put
those coins in the bank,
but then I'll be able to
use them for deletion.
So this is what
insertion is going to do.
I can store credit
in the bank, and then
separately we allow an operation
to take coins out of the bank,
and you can pay for time
using the credit that's
been stored in the bank.
As long as the bank
balance remains
non-negative at all
times, this will be good.
The bank balance is a
sort of unused time.
We're paying for it to
store things in there.
If we don't use
it, well, we just
have an upper bound on time.
As long as we go
non-negative, then
the summation will always
be in the right direction.
This inequality will hold.
Let's do an example.
Well, maybe this
is a first example.
So when I do an
insertion, I can put,
let's say, one coin of value
log n star into the bank, and so
the total cost of
that insertion,
I pay log n star real cost
in order to do the insertion,
then I also pay log n
star for those coins
to put them in the bank.
When I do a deletion, the
real cost is log n star,
but I'm going to extract
out of it log n star coins,
and so the total
cost is actually
free-- the total
amortized cost is free--
and the reason that works, the
reason the balance is always
non-negative, is because
for every deletion
there was an
insertion before it.
So that's maybe a
less intuitive way
to think about this
problem, but you
could think about it that way.
More generally-- so
what we'd like to say
is that we only put
log n without the star,
the current value
of n per insert
and a 0 per delete amortized.
So we'd like to
say, OK, let me put
one coin worth log n for each
insertion, and when I delete,
I consume the coin.
And, in general,
the formula here
is that the amortized
cost of an operation
is the actual cost plus the
deposits minus the withdrawals.
OK.
So insertion, we
just double the cost,
because we pay log
n to the real thing,
we pay log n to store the coin.
That's the plus deposit
part, so insertion remains
log n, and then deletion, we
pay log n to do the deletion,
but then we subtract off
the coin of value log n,
so that hopefully
works out to zero 0.
But, again, we have this
issue that coins actually
have different amounts,
depending on what
the current value of n was.
You can actually get
this to work if you say,
well, there are coins
of varying values here,
and I think the
invariant is if you
have a current
structure of size n,
you will have one coin of size
log 1, log 2, log 3, log 4,
up to log n.
Each coin corresponds to the
item that made n that value.
And so when you delete
an item at size n,
you'll be removing the log nth
coin, the coin of value log n.
So you can actually get this
to work if you're careful.
I guess the invariant is one
coin of value log i for i
equals 1 to n, and you can
check that invariant holds.
When I do a new insertion,
I increase n by 1
and I make a new coin
of log that value.
When I do a deletion,
I'm going to remove
that last coin of log n.
So this does work out.
So we got rid of the end star.
OK, let's use this same method
to analyze table doubling.
We already know why
table doubling works,
but good to think of it
from different perspectives.
And it's particularly
fun to think of the coins
as being physical objects
in the data structure.
I always thought it would fun
to put this in a programming
language, but I
don't think there
is a programming language that
has coins in it in this sense
yet.
Maybe you can fix that.
So let's go back
to table doubling.
Let's say when we insert
an item into a table,
and here I'm just
going to do insertions.
We'll worry about
deletions in a moment.
Whenever I do an
insertion, I'm going
to put a coin on that item,
and the value of the coin
is going to be a constant.
I going to give the constant a
name so we can be a little more
precise in a moment-- c.
So here's kind of the typical--
well, here's an array.
We start with an
array of size 1,
and we insert a single item
here, and we put a coin on it.
Maybe I'll draw the coin in
a color, which I've lost.
Here.
So I insert some item x, and
I put a coin on that item.
When I do the next
insertion, let's
say I have to double
the table to size 2.
I'm going to use
up that coin, so
erase it, put a new coin on
the item that I just put down.
Call it y.
In general-- so the next time
I double, which is immediately,
I'm going to go to size 4.
I erase this coin,
then I put a coin here.
When I insert item, of
course, letter after z is w.
Then I put another coin
when I have to double again,
so here I'm going to use
these coins to charge
for the doubling, and
then in the next round,
I'm going to be
inserting here, here,
and here, and I'll be
putting a coin here, here,
here, and here.
In general, you start
to see the pattern--
so I used up these
guys-- that by the time
I have to double again, half
of the items have coins,
the other half don't,
because I already used them.
You have to be careful not to
use a coin twice, because you
only get to use it once.
You can't divide money
into double money
unless you're doing
stocks, I guess.
As soon as I get to a place
where the array is completely
full when n equals m, the
last half of the items
will have coins.
I'm going to use them in
order to pay for the doubling,
so the number of coins
here will be n over 2.
So this is why I wanted
to make this constant
a little explicit, because
it has to be bigger than 2
in some sense.
However much work-- let's say
it takes a times n work in order
to do doubling,
then this constant
should be something
like two times a,
because I need to do
the work to double,
but I only have n over
2 coins to pay for it.
I don't get coins over here.
So when we double, the last
n over 2 items have coins,
and so the amortized cost
of the doubling operation
is going to be the
real cost, which
is sum theta n minus the
number of coins I can remove
and their value.
So it's going to be
minus c times n over 2
and, the point is, this
is 0 if we set c large.
It only has to be a constant.
It needs to be bigger than
2 times that constant.
And usually when you're
working with coins,
you want to make the
constants explicit just
to make sure there's no circular
dependence on constants,
make sure there is a valid
choice of c that annihilates
whatever cost you
want to get rid of.
So this is the accounting
method view of table doubling.
Any questions so far?
So far so good.
Pretty simple example.
Let's get to more
interesting examples.
You also think about the
amortized cost of an insert.
It costs constant real time.
Actual cost is constant.
You have to also
deposit one coin, which
costs constant time so the
amortized cost of the insert
is still constant.
So that's good.
Still we don't know how
to deal with deletions,
but let me give you a kind
of reverse perspective
on the accounting method.
It's, again, equivalent
in a certain sense,
but in another sense
may be more intuitive
some of the time
for some people.
It's actually not
in the textbook,
but it's the one I
use the most so I
figure it's worth teaching.
It's called the charging method.
It's also a little bit more
time travel-y, if you will,
so if you like time travel,
this method is for you,
or maybe a more
pessimistic view is blaming
the past for your mistakes.
So what we're going
to do is allow--
there's no bank balance anymore,
although it's essentially
there.
We're going to allow operations
to charge some of their cost
retroactively to the
past, not the future.
I actually have a
data structures paper
which proves that while
time travel to the past
is plausible, time travel to the
future is not computationally.
So you're not allowed to
time travel to the future,
only allowed to go to the
past, and say, hey, give me $5.
But you've got to be a little
bit conservative in how
you do it.
You can't just keep charging the
same operation a million times,
because then the cost of
that operation is going up.
At the end of the
day, every operation
had to have paid for
its total charge.
So there's the actual
cost, which it starts with,
and then there's whatever it's
being charged by the future.
So from an analysis
perspective, you're
thinking about the future.
What could
potentially charge me?
Again, you can define the
amortized cost of an operation
is going to be the actual
cost minus the total charge
to the past.
So when we charge
to the past, we
get free dollars in
the present, but we
have to pay for whatever
the future is going to do.
So we have to imagine
how many times could I
get charged in the future?
I'm going to have to pay for
that now in a consistent time
line.
You will have to have paid for
things that come in the future.
So let's do an example.
Actually it sounds
crazy and weird,
but I actually find this
a lot more intuitive
to think about even
these very examples.
Let's start with table doubling.
So we have this kind
of picture already.
It's going to be
pretty much the same.
After I've doubled the
table, my array is half full
and, again, insertion only,
although we'll insertion
and deletion in the moment.
In order to get from half
full to completely full,
I have to do n
over 2 insertions.
It's looking very similar,
but what I'm going to say
is that when I double
the array next time,
I'm going to charge that
doubling to those operations.
In general, you can actually say
this quite concisely-- whenever
I do a doubling
operation, I'm going
to charge it to
all the insertions
since the last doubling.
That's a very
clear set of items.
Doublings happen, and then they
don't happen for a while, just
all those insertions
that happened
since the last doubling
charged to them.
And how many are there?
Well, as we've argued,
there are n over 2 of them,
and the cost of-- in order
to make this doubling free,
I need to charge theta n.
So this doubling cost
theta n, but there's
n over things to charge to.
I'm going to uniformly
distribute my charge
to them, which
means I'm charging
a constant amount to each.
And the key fact here is that
I only charge an insert once.
Because of this
since clause, I never
will charge an
item twice as long
as I'm only inserting for now.
If you look over all
time, you will only
charge an insert once.
That's good, because
the inserts have
to pay for their total
charge in the future.
There's only one charge, and
it's only a constant amount,
then amortized cost
of insert is still
constant, amortized
cost of doubling is 0,
because we charged the
entire cost to the past.
So same example, but slightly
different perspective.
Let's do a more interesting
example-- inserts and deletes
in a table.
Let' say I want to maintain
that the size of the table
is always within a constant
factor of the number of items
currently in the table.
If I just want an upper bound,
then I only need to double,
but if I want also
a lower bound--
if I don't want the
table to be too empty,
then I need to
add table halving.
So what I'm going to do is
when the table is 100% full,
I double its size, when
the table is 50% full,
should I halve it in size?
Would that work?
No, because--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have to have it inserted
in place of linear [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
I can basically do insert,
delete, insert, delete, insert,
delete, and every
single operation costs
linear time, because maybe
I'm a little bit less
than half full-- sorry, yeah, if
I'm a little bit less than half
full, then I'm going to
shrink the array into half.
Get rid of this part, then
if I immediately insert,
it becomes 100% full again.
I have to double in size,
and then if I delete,
it becomes less than half full,
and I have to halve in size.
Every operation would
cost linear time,
so amortized cost
is linear time.
That's not good.
So what I'll do is just separate
those constants a little bit.
When I'm 100% full,
I will double.
That seems pretty
clear, but let's say
when I'm a quarter
full, then I will halve.
Any value less than 50 would
work here, but-- just halve,
like that.
This will actually work.
This will be constant
amortized per operation,
but it's-- especially the
initial analysis we did
of table doubling isn't
going to work here,
because it's complicated.
The thing's going to
shrink and grow over time.
Just summing that is not easy.
It depends on the
sequence of operations,
but with charging
and also with coins,
we could do it in
a pretty clean way.
I'm going to do
it with charging.
So this particular
choice of constants
is nice, because when I double
a full array, it's half full,
and also when I
have an array that's
a quarter full, like this,
and then I divide it--
and then I shrink it--
I get rid of this part,
it's also half full.
So whenever I do a
double or a halve,
the new array is half full, 50%.
That's nice.
That's nice, because 50% is far
away from both 25% and 100%.
So our nice state is right
after a doubling or a halve,
then we know that
our structure is 50%.
In order to get to an
under-flowing state
where we have to halve, I have
to delete at least a quarter
of the items, a quarter of m.
In order to get to overflowing
where I have to double,
I have to insert at
least m over 2 items.
Either way, a constant
fraction times m, that's
what I'm going to charge to.
Now, to be clear,
when I'm 50% full,
I might insert, delete, insert,
delete, many different inserts
and deletes.
At some point, one
of these two things
is going to happen though.
In order to get here, I have to
do at least m over 4 deletions.
I might also do more
insertions and deletions,
but I have to do
at least that many,
and those are the ones
I'm going to charge to.
So I'm going to charge
a halving operation
to the at least m
over 4 deletions
since the last resize of either
type, doubling or halving.
And I'm going to
charge the doubling
to the at least m
over 2 insertions
since the last resize.
OK, and that's it.
Because the halving costs
theta m time, doubling costs
theta m time, I have theta
m operations to charge to,
so I'm only charging constant
for each of the operations.
And because of this
since last resize clause,
it's clear that you're never
charging an operation more
than once, because
you can divide time
by when the resizes happen,
grows or shrinks, halves
or doubles.
And each resize is only charging
to the past a window of time.
So it's like you have epics
of time, you separate them,
you only charge
within your epic.
OK, so that's cool.
So you only get
a constant number
of charges per item
of a constant amount,
therefore insertions
and deletions
are constant amortized.
Halving and doubling
is free amortized.
Clear?
This is where amortization
starts to get interesting.
You can also think of this
example in terms of coins,
but with putting
coins on the items,
but then you have to think
about the invariance of where
the coins are, which I
find to be more work.
We actually had
to do it up here.
I was claiming the last
half of the items had coins.
You have to prove that really.
With this method, you don't.
I mean, what you have to prove
is that there are enough things
to charge to.
We had to prove here that
there were n over 2 items
to charge to.
Kind of the same thing,
but it was very clear
that you weren't charging to
the same thing more than once.
You were never trying to
use a coin that wasn't there
because of the since clause.
To each their own.
I think either way would work.
I think I will
skip this example,
but I'll just mention it.
So for 2-3 trees, we
said deletions were free,
and we did that with
the coin invariant,
that there was one coin
of size log i for each i.
You could instead say,
when I delete an item,
I'm going to charge
it to the insert that
made n this current value,
because that insert paid
log n the actual
cost, so it can afford
to pay another log n
to pay for the deletion
of some other item, the one
we're currently deleting.
And that works, that you don't
double charge to an insert,
because you're
decreasing n right now.
So for n to get up
to that value again,
you would have had
to do another insert.
So same thing, slightly
different perspective.
Let's go to something
even more interesting
and in some sense more powerful,
the last method on the list,
which is potential method.
This is a good exercise in how
many ways can you skin a cat?
So potential method, I like
to call it defining karma
in a formal way, is more
like the counting strategy.
We're going to think
about there being a bank
account with some
balance, but we're
going to define that balance
as a function of the data
structure state.
So that's called the
potential function,
but you can think of
it as a bank balance.
You can think of it as
kinetic potential, I guess.
Potential energy.
Just like the bank account, we
want this function to always
be non-negative.
We'll also make it an integer.
That would be convenient.
The potential
function is basically
trying to measure how bad is
the data structure right now?
It's, again, like saving
up for a rainy day.
We want that whenever we have
to do an expensive operation,
like a double or halve, that
this potential has grown
large enough that we
can charge that cost
to a decrease in the potential.
So it's like this is
storing up energy,
and whenever we
have some free time,
we'll give some of that time
to the potential function.
It's just like the accounting
method, in a certain sense,
but we're defining
things differently.
Over here, we explicitly
said, hey look, I'm
going to store some
credit right now.
So we were basically
specifying the delta,
and here we're saying I'm going
to consume some credit right
now.
Over here, we're going to
define this magical function
of the current state.
From that you can compute the
deltas, but also from here
you can integrate and compute
the potential function.
So they're interchangeable,
but usually it's
easier to think about one
perspective or the other.
Really often, you can
just look at what's
going on with the data
structure and say,
hey, you know, this aspect
of the data structure
makes it bad, makes
costly operations,
and you can just define
the potential function,
then just check that it works.
But it's a little
bit of black magic
to come up with these
functions, so you depends how
you like to think about things.
So, as before, we can
define an amortized cost.
It's going to be the
actual cost plus the change
in the potential.
So change of potential
is just the potential
after the operation minus the
potential before the operation.
I highlight that, and it's
kind of obvious from the way
we set things up, but
what I care about is
the sum of the amortized costs.
I care about that,
because it's supposed
to be an upper bound on the
sum of the actual costs.
And if you just look
at what that sum is,
on the right-hand
side I have amortized
cost plus the fee after
the operation minus the fee
before the operation.
If I add all those up,
this part telescopes
or you get cancellation
from each term
with the previous term.
The sum of the
amortized costs is
equal to the sum of the
actual costs plus phi
at the end minus phi
at the beginning.
So a slight catch with
the potential method.
When you define things
this way, you also
have to pay for phi
at the beginning,
because we want the actual cost
to be, at most, amortized cost.
So we need to take this
apart and put it over here
so it's, at most,
some of amortized cost
plus phi of the beginning.
This part becomes negative,
so we usually just ignore it.
It can only help us.
So when you define a
potential function,
you'd really like it to
be 0 at the beginning.
It's funny, but you pay
phi of the beginning state
at the beginning of time, and
when you've done 0 operations,
you really like
the cost to be 0,
and you don't want to
have to have stored stuff
in the bank, so this should
be a-- constant would probably
be OK, or whatever the cost
of your first operation
is but should be constant or 0.
Usually we do this
by saying, look,
let's start with an empty
structure and work from there.
Usually phi of an
empty structure is 0,
and all is well.
So when you're defining things
with potential function,
you have to be careful
about your initial state.
You have to make sure
it's non-negative
just like you did
over here, but you
didn't have to worry about
this part over there.
All this infrastructure,
what's it good for?
Let's do some examples.
These are going to be the
most interesting examples.
A kind of classic
example of amortization
is incrementing
a binary counter.
So when you have some
binary value like this one
and you increment
it, many bits change,
but only a constant
number are going
to change in an amortized sense.
If I start with a 0
vector, 0 bit vector,
and I increment-- well, the
very first increment costs 1,
the next increment costs 2,
the next increment costs 1,
next increment costs 3, then
1, then 2, then 1, then 4,
then it's a fractal.
But instead of thinking
about that fractal
and working hard to
prove that summation
is linear for an operation,
let's use the potential method.
And the intuition here
is actually pretty easy,
because an increment
has a very clear cost.
It's just the number
of trailing 1s plus 1.
That's what it is
in actual cost.
We'd like that to be
constant so, intuitively,
what is making an increment bad?
If you had to name one thing?
If I just look at a
configuration, is this bad?
Is this bad?
How bad is the configuration?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The more
trailing ones you have,
the worse the state is?
ERIK DEMAINE: The more trailing
ones, the worse the state is.
So that's one
natural definition.
Turns out, it won't work.
Let's see why.
I think here's an example.
So near the end of
our increment stage,
we have a whole bunch of
1s but no trailing 1s,
number of trailing 1s is 0.
If I do a single increment, now
the number of trailing 1s is n,
so if you look at
the amortized cost,
it's the actual cost
plus the change in phi
and so I actually pay
n for that operation
in the amortized sense,
and that's no good.
We only want to pay constant,
but it's on the right track.
So number of trailing 1, it
is the natural thing to try,
but it doesn't quite work
for our definition of phi.
Other ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The total
number of [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: The
total number of 1s.
Yeah.
Let's define phi, could
be the number of 1 bits.
That will work, but
you both get a Frisbee.
AUDIENCE: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Sorry.
Good thing I missed.
Number 1 bits.
Intuitively, 1s are bad, and
this is a good definition,
because when I increment
I only create one 1,
so I'm not going to have this
issue that delta phi goes up
by a lot-- sorry, that
phi goes up by a lot,
that delta phi is really large.
Because even in this
scenario, if I increment,
I only add one 1.
In this scenario, I destroy
three 1s and add one.
In general, if there are,
let's say, t trailing bits,
then an increment destroys t 1
bits, and it creates one 1 bit.
That's always what happens.
T could be 0, and then I
have a net positive of 1,
but most of the time actually
I destroy 1 bits-- well,
more than half the
time I destroy 1 bits,
and I just create a
single 1 bit, in terms
of the total number of 1s.
So the amortized cost
is the actual cost,
which is this 1 plus t.
I'm actually going to
remove the-- well, yeah.
I'd like to remove
the big O if I could.
I'm going to
count-- I want to be
a little bit precise
about my counting,
because I have to do
a minus sign here.
If I just wrote minus
t, that doesn't quite
work out, because
there's a constant here
that I have to annihilate.
If I count the number
of bits that change,
then that's exactly 1
plus t in an increment.
And now the change of potential
is that I decrease by t,
I increase by 1, I get 0.
That seems a little bit too
small, 0 time per operation.
AUDIENCE: You're
adding a 1, you're
not subtracting [INAUDIBLE].
Sorry, you're not
subtracting [INAUDIBLE].
Just subtracting something else.
ERIK DEMAINE: Oh, right, sorry.
That's 2.
Thank you.
I just can't do the arithmetic.
I wrote everything correct, but
this is a plus 1 and a plus 1.
T minus t is the key
part that cancels.
Now, if you were measuring
running time instead
of the number of
changed bits, you'd
have to have a big O
here, and in that case
you'd have to define phi to be
some constant times the number
of 1 bits.
So you could still set
that constant large
enough so that this part,
which is multiplied by c,
would annihilate
this part, which
would have a big O. I guess
I'll write it in just for kicks
so you've seen both versions.
This would be minus c see
times t plus 1 times c.
So that would still work out.
If you set c to the right
value, you will still get 2.
So binary counters,
constant amortize operation.
So I think this is
very clean, much easier
than analyzing the
fractal of the costs.
Now, binary counter with
increment and decrements,
that doesn't work.
There are other data
structures to do it,
but that's for another class.
Let's go back to 2-3 trees,
because I have more interesting
things to say about them.
Any questions about
binary counters?
As you saw, it wasn't
totally easy to define
a potential function,
but we're going
to see-- if see
enough examples, you
get some intuition for
them, but it is probably
the hardest method to use but
also kind of the most powerful.
I would say all
hard amortizations
use a potential function.
That's just life.
Finding them is tough.
That's reality.
I want to analyze insertions
only in 2-3 trees,
then we'll do insertions
and deletions,
and I want to count how
many splits in a 2-3 tree
when I do an insertion.
So remember, when you
insert into a 2-3 tree,
so you started a leaf,
you insert a key there.
If it's too big,
you split that node
into two parts, which
causes an insert of a key
into the parent.
Then that might be too big,
and you split, and so on.
So total number of
splits per insert?
Upper bounds?
AUDIENCE: Log n.
ERIK DEMAINE: Log n.
OK.
Definitely log n
in the worst case.
That's sort of the actual cost
but, as you may be guessing,
I claim the amortized number
of splits is only constant,
and first will prove
this with insertion only.
With insertion and
deletion in a 2-3 tree,
it's actually not true, but for
insertion only this is true.
So let's prove it.
A 2-3 tree, we have two types
of nodes, 2 nodes and 3 nodes.
I'm counting the
number of children,
not the number of
keys, is one smaller
than the number of children.
Sorry, no vertical line there.
This is just sum key
x, sum key and y.
So when I insert
a key into a node,
it momentarily becomes
a 4 node, you might say,
with has three
keys, x, y, and z.
So 4 node, it has four
children, hence the 4,
and we split it into x and z.
There's the four
children, same number,
but now they're distributed
between x and z.
And then y gets promoted
to the next level up,
which allows us to have
two pointers to x and z.
And that's how 2-3 trees work.
That's how split works.
Now, I want to say
that splitting-- I
want to charge the splitting
to something, intuitively.
Let's say y was the
key that was inserted,
so we started with x
z, which was a 3 node.
When we did an insert,
it became a 4 node,
and then we did a
split, which left us
with two 2 nodes and something.
So what can you say
overall about this process?
What's making this example bad?
What's making the split
happen, in some sense?
I mean, the insert is
one thing, but there's
another thing we can charge to.
Insert's not enough, because
we're going to do log n splits,
and we can only
charge to the insert
once if we want constant
amortized bound.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Number of 3 nodes?
ERIK DEMAINE: Number
of 3 nodes, exactly.
That's a good
potential function,
because on the left side of
this picture, we had one 3 node.
On the right side of the
picture, we had two 2 nodes.
Now, what's happening
to the parent?
We'll have to worry
about that in a moment,
but you've got the intuition.
Number of 3 nodes.
I looked at just a
single operation here,
but if you look more generally
about an expensive insert,
in that it does many splits,
the only way that can happen
is if you had a chain of 3 nodes
all connected to each other
and you do an insert down here.
This one splits, then this one
splits, then this one splits.
So there are all these 3
nodes just hanging around,
and after you do the split,
the parent of the very
last node that splits,
that might become a 3 node.
So that will be
up here somewhere.
You might have made
one new 3 node,
but then this one is
a couple of 2 nodes,
this becomes a
couple of 2 nodes,
and this becomes a
couple of 2 nodes.
So if you had k 3 nodes before,
afterwards you have one.
Sound familiar?
This is actually
exactly what's going on
with the binary counter, so this
may seem like a toy example,
but over here we created,
at most, one 1 bit.
Down here we create,
at most, one 3 node,
which is when the split stops.
When the split stops,
that's the only time
we actually insert a key into
a node and it doesn't split,
because otherwise you split.
When you split, you're
always making two nodes,
and that's good.
At the very end when
you stop splitting,
you might have made one 3 node.
So in an insert, let's say
the number of splits equals k,
then the change of
potential for that operation
is minus k plus 1,
because for every split
there was a 3 node to charge
to-- or for every split
there was a 3 node that
became two nodes, two 2 nodes.
So the potential
went down by one,
because you used to have
one 3 node, then you had 0.
At the very end, you
might create one 3 node.
That's the plus 1.
So the amortized cost is just
the sum of these two things,
and we get 1.
That's k minus k
plus 1 which is 1.
Cool, huh?
This is where a potential method
becomes powerful, I would say.
You can view this as a
kind of charging argument,
but it gets very confusing.
Maybe with coins is
the most plausible use.
Essentially, the
invariance you'd want
is that you have a
coin on every 3 node.
Same thing, of course,
but it's I think easier
to think about it this way.
Say, well, 3 nodes seem
to be the bad thing.
Let's just count them,
let's just see what happens.
It's more like you
say I want to have
this invariant that there's
a coin on every 3 node.
How can I achieve that?
And it just works magically,
because A, it helps it was true
and, B, we had to come up with
the right potential function.
And those are tricky and, in
general with amortization,
unless you're told on a p
set prove order t amortize,
you don't always know what
the right running time is,
and you just have to experiment.
Our final example,
most impressive.
Let's go over here.
It's a surprise, I guess.
It's not even on the list.
I want to do-- this
is great for inserts,
but what about deletes?
I want to do
inserts and deletes.
I'd like to do 2-3 trees,
but 2-3 trees don't work.
If I want to get a constant
amortized bound for inserts
and deletes, I've got to
constant advertised here
for inserts-- I should be clear.
I'm ignoring the
cost of searching.
Let's just say searching
is cheap for some reason.
Maybe you already know
where your key is,
and you just want
to insert there.
Then insert only costs constant
amortize in a 2-3 tree.
Insert and delete
is not that good.
It can be log n
for every operation
if I do inserts and deletes,
essentially for the same reason
that a binary counter can
be n for every operation
if I do increments
and decrements.
I could be here,
increment a couple times,
and then I change a
huge number of bits.
If I immediately decrement,
then all the bits go back.
In increment, all
the bits go back.
Decrement, all the bits go back.
So I'm changing end
bits in every operation.
In the same way, if you just
think of one path of your tree,
and you think of the
0 bits as 2 nodes
and the 1 bits as 3
nodes, when I increment
by inserting at the
bottom, all those 3s
turn to 1, except
the top I make a 3.
That's just like
a binary counter.
It went from all
1s to 1 0 0 0 0 0,
and then if I
decrement, if I delete
from that very
same leaf, then I'm
going to have to do
merges all the way back up
and turn those all back
into 3 nodes again.
And so every operation
is going to pay log n.
Log n's, not so bad, but
I really want constant.
So I'm going to introduce
something new called 2-5 trees,
and it's going to be exactly
like b trees that you learned,
except now the number of
children of every node
should be between 2 and 5.
All the operations
are defined the same.
We've already
talked about insert.
Now insert-- when you
have six children,
then you're
overflowing, and then
you're going to split
in half and so on.
So actually I should
draw that picture,
because we're going to need it.
So if I started with a 5 node,
which means it has four keys,
and then I insert into
it, I get a 6 node.
That's too many.
Six children.
OK, that's too
much, so I'm going
to split it in
half, which is going
to leave a 3 node
and a single item,
which gets promoted to the
parent, and another 3 node.
OK, so we started with a 5 node,
and the result was two 3 nodes.
OK, that split, and
we also contaminate
the parent a little
bit, but that
may lead to another split,
which will look like this again.
So if we're just
doing insertions,
fine, we just count the number
of 5 nodes, no different,
right?
But I want to do simultaneously
insert and delete.
So let's remember what
happens with a delete.
So if you just delete
a key and a leaf,
the issue is it may
become too empty.
So what's too empty?
Well, the minimum
number of children
we're allowed to have
is two, so too empty
would be that I have one child.
So maybe initially
I have two children,
and I have a single key
x, then maybe I delete
x, and so now I have 0 keys.
This is a 1 node.
It has a single child.
OK.
Weird.
In that case, there are
sort of two situations.
Maybe your sibling
has enough keys
that you can just steal one,
then that was really cheap.
But the other case
is that you-- yeah.
I'm also going to have
to involve my parent,
so maybe I'm going
to take a key from x
and merge all these
things together.
So that's y, then
what I get is an x y.
I had two children here,
three children here.
OK.
Also messed up my
parent a little bit,
but that's going to
be the recursive case.
This is a sort of
merge operation.
In general, I merge
with my sibling
and then potentially
split again,
or you can think of it as
stealing from your sibling,
as you may be
experienced with doing.
I don't have siblings, so
I didn't get to do that,
but I stole from my
parents, so whatever.
However you want
to think about it,
that is merging in a b tree.
We started with a 2 node here.
We ended up with a 3 node.
Hmm, that's good.
It's different at least.
So the bad case
here is a 5 node,
bad case here is a 2 node.
What should I use a
potential function?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Number of
nodes with two children
and number of nodes
with five children?
ERIK DEMAINE: Number
of nodes with two
or five children, yeah.
So that's it.
Just combine with the sum.
That's going to be the number
of nodes with two children
plus the number of nodes
with five children.
This is measuring karma.
This is how bad is
my tree going to be,
because if I have 2 nodes, I'm
really close to under flowing
and that's potentially bad.
If I happen to delete there,
bad things are going to happen.
If I have a bunch of 5 nodes,
splits could happen there,
and I don't know whether
it's going to be an insert
or delete next,
so I'm just going
to keep track of both of them.
And luckily neither of
them output 5s or 2s.
If they did, like
if we did 2-3 trees,
this is a total
nightmare, because you
can't count the number of 2
nodes plus the number 3 nodes.
That's all the nodes.
Potential only changes
by 1 in each step.
That would never help you.
OK?
But here we have enough
of a gap between the lower
bound and the upper bound and,
in general, any constants here
will work.
These are usually
called a-b trees,
generalization of
b trees, where you
get to specify the lower
bound and the upper bound, as
long as a-- what's
the way-- as long as a
is strictly less than b over 2,
then this argument will work.
As long as there's at least
one gap between a and b over 2,
then this argument will work,
because in the small case,
you start with the
minimum number of children
you can have.
You'll get one more in the end,
and in the other situation,
you have too many
things, you divide by 2,
and you don't want
dividing by 2 to end up
with the bad case over here.
That's what happened
even with 2-4 trees--
2-3-4 trees-- but with 2-5
trees, there's enough of a gap
that when we split 5 in
half, we get 3s only, no 2s,
and when we merge
2s, we get 3s, no 5s.
So in either case,
if we do the split--
if we do an insert with k
splits, the change in potential
is minus k plus 1.
Again, we might make a single
five-child node at the top when
we stop splitting, but
every time we split,
we've taken a 5 node
and destroyed it,
left it with two 3 nodes,
so that decreases by k,
and so this k cost gets
cancelled out by this negative
k and change potential, so the
amortized cost is 1 just like
before.
But now, also with delete,
with k merge operations
where I'm treating all
of this as one operation,
again, the change of
potential is minus k plus 1.
Potentially when
we stop merging,
because we stole one
key from our parent,
it may now be a 2 node,
whereas before it wasn't.
If it was already a 2 node,
then it would be another merge,
and that's actually
a good case for us,
but when the merges
stop, they stop
because we hit a node
that's at least a 3 node,
then we delete a key from it,
so potentially it's a 2 node.
So potentially the
potential goes up by 1.
We make one new bad
node, but every time
we do a merge, we
destroy bad nodes,
because we started
with a 2 node,
we turned it into a 3 node.
So, again, the amortized
cost is the actual cost,
which is k, plus the
change in potential,
which is minus k plus 1, and so
the amortized cost is just 1.
Constant number of splits or
merges per insert or delete.
So this is actually
really nice if you're
in a model where changing
your data structure
is more expensive than
searching your data structure.
For example, you have a lot of
threads in parallel accessing
your thing.
You're on a multi-core
machine or something.
You have a shared
data structure,
you really don't want to be
changing things very often,
because you have to take a
lock and then that slows down
all the other threads.
If searches are
really fast but splits
and merges are
expensive, then this
is a reason why you should use
2-5 trees instead of 2-3 trees,
because 2-3 trees,
they'll be splitting
emerging all the time, log n.
It's not a huge
difference, log n
versus constant, but
with data structures
that's usually the gap.
Last class we were super
excited, because we
went from log to log log.
Here we're excited we
go from log to constant.
It's a little better, but
they're all small numbers,
but still we like to go
fast, as fast as possible.
In a real system, actually
it's even more important,
because splitting the root
is probably the worst,
because everyone is
always touching the root.
In a 2-5 tree, you
almost never touch
the root, almost always
splitting and merging
at the leaves,
whereas in a 2-3 tree,
you could be going all the way
to the root every single time.
So that's my examples.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: For free minutes.
Cool.
That's amortization.